atteints de cancers avancés du côlon
thomas soit on cherchait un moyen
d'atténuer son anxiété liée à son
diagnostic et à la perspective de la
mort en 2020 il a reçu une rares
exemptions d'ottawa lui permettant de
suivre une thérapie par psilocybine des
champignons magiques les effets ont été
immenses confie-t-il
cette année il a pu renouveler
l'expérience cette fois grâce à un
changement de réglementation depuis
janvier santé canada permet aux médecins
dans le cadre du programme d'accès
spéciale de demander à prescrire des
drogues psychédéliques un patient sous
strictes conditions et supervision en
six mois plus d'une trentaine de
demandes ont été reçues
une avancée pour ce médecin mais il
souligne que le processus demeure
laborieux est limité
il faut des incitatifs pour que les gens
se soignent dans un espace sûr dit il
pour éviter qu'ils risquent
l'automédication pour l'instant avant
d'envisager d'autres changements santé
canada attend de pouvoir s'appuyer sur
plus d'études
[Musique]
une bonne démarche scientifique est
primordiale note ce chercheur il
s'apprête justement à lancer des essais
cliniques sur le micro dosage de
psilocybine
le développement de ce domaine commence
aussi en même temps a suscité l'intérêt
d'investisseurs constate cette avocate
des compagnies prêtes à mettre de
l'argent dans la recherche ou de futur
centre de traitement
dernier dès qu'on dit elle nous avions
une soixantaine de sociétés inscrites à
la bourse
le début peut être d'une certaine
renaissance pour ces substances
ici camille guiraud à radio canada
toronto